>> Manuel Roig-Franzia: My
name is Manuel Roig Franzia.
I'm a reporter at
the Washington post.
And I'd like to welcome you
all to this very special event.
First off, we wanted to thank
our cochairman of the festival,
David Rubenstein and other
sponsors of this event
and wanted to point out that
if you are also interested
in supporting the festival,
you can look in your program
for information about
doing that.
Also, we're very fortunate
that today Professor Jackson has
agreed to take some questions.
So if after his presentation,
you would like to ask him
about this very interesting
work of his,
please come to the
microphones and smile pretty
because I'm told that it
may be appearing later
on videos or on television.
It's my pleasure to introduce
you to Lawrence P. Jackson,
prolific author and professor.
He has produced a
very comprehensive
and interesting biography of
an author we should all know
about named Chester Himes.
Now, Professor Jackson
knows a bit
about well-known authors
in the United States.
He also is the author of a
biography of Ralph Ellison.
And myself as a person born in
Spain, I was interested to learn
that Chester Himes spent a
good deal of time in Spain
in the City of Alicante, just
one of the many surprises,
I think, that you'll find in
this very interesting work.
So with no further ado,
I will hand the stage
to Professor Jackson and I think
you will look forward to hearing
about this book that has
really shined a light
on a very interesting
figure in American Letters.
Professor Jackson.
[ Applause ]
>> Lawrence P. Jackson:
Good afternoon, everyone.
Can you hear me?
Thank you so much for coming.
I really appreciate it.
I brought my book, the other
books that I've written before
because yesterday I
realized that no one knew
who Chester Himes was and I was
pretty sure they didn't know
who Professor Jackson
was either.
And you have come to the
National Book Festival
and unfortunately you're
going to get something
of an academic lecture.
So please bear with me because
I have a number of slides
that I think are fascinating.
I will go through them very
rapidly so that we can have time
for a dialogue and I
really look forward
to hearing from your questions.
So I started work
on this project,
biography of Chester Himes,
you know, sort of the unknown
of the four famous mid 20th
century African-American
writers, Richard
Wright, Ralph Ellison,
James Baldwin and Chester Himes.
I started collecting
research in 2003
and it's been an
amazing journey.
So Chester Himes was born
in Jefferson City, Missouri
and his claim to fame was that
he came from what amounted
to an upper-middle-class
African-American family.
You can see Chester in
the christening dress
with his older brothers and
the two brothers, Chester
and Joseph Sandy Himes Jr.,
they were only separated
by about 18 months, so
they really grew up in sort
of close companionship.
And Chester's father was
a blacksmithing instructor
at Lincoln University.
Lincoln and if you've just come
from the Ron Chernow lecture
was founded by members
of the United States
Colored Troops.
So, African-American
soldiers at the end
of the Civil War actually
founded a college in Missouri
and it was explicitly
designed to cater to the needs
of freed people, right?
It was going to-- as we, you
know, we're talking yesterday,
David M. Rubenstein was
talking about the crisis
of functional illiteracy in the
United States and the connection
between illiteracy and
social income inequality.
This was actually on the agenda
of African-American soldiers
at the end of the Civil War.
So Joseph Sandy Himes was
a blacksmith instructor.
He's in the center
of this photograph,
sort of the small man with
the apron in the back.
And he design things
for his family.
He was sort of the apple
of his children's eye.
But things were not always
easy in their household
and they left Lincoln after sort
of the Booker T. Washington
machine, I think, you know,
decided that maybe he was
a little bit too radical
and they went to Mississippi.
Now, of course, it was also--
they're going there about 1913.
So it's also at that
time that his expertise
in blacksmithing was becoming
absolutely outmoded, right?
So I say that he went some place
where the 19th century
was on more sure-footing.
So they went to Alcorn,
Mississippi.
So Chester's mother was
a very, very accomplished
and extremely well-educated
African-American woman named
Estelle Bomar Himes.
And I-- you know, you can't
see his dad but so well
in the picture, but his father
was a dark brown skinned
African-American man and
his mother was very, very--
well, we used to use the
euphemism fair skinned, very,
very light complexioned
African-American woman
who sometimes chose to pass
for white to avail herself
of services like the
dentist in Mississippi
that were unavailable
to African-Americans
she very strongly chafed
against the restrictions
of racial segregation.
Chester Himes always
said that his father more
or less accepted the
second-class citizenship.
Some of us believe that
there's only citizenship or not,
but nonetheless, that
he accepted the role
of subservience that you
had to play for survival.
And that his mother
absolutely rejected it.
And of the two parents
when he was a child,
he began to be really drawn
towards his mother's point
of view.
However, it created a great deal
of friction inside of their home
and they moved again
to Pine Bluff,
Arkansas to another
African-American normal school,
which is today a
branch of the University
of Arkansas at Pine Bluff.
And in 1924, Chester
Himes's brother was very,
very badly injured in a
chemistry experience gone awry.
So his brother was
only 18 months older,
wound up losing his sight.
So the family moved to St.
Louis to go to the hospital
that was available
to African-Americans
for really complicated
surgical operations,
the Barnes Hospital
in St. Louis.
And they bought a house not
far from Sumner High School
where Chester Himes
would go to school.
But as you can sort of see
from this pattern already he
was moving around quite a bit
as a young person and
becoming a little bit unmoored.
The family-- The Himes
family had two branches.
And one of the branches of the
family had moved to Cleveland,
Ohio where there was a
great deal of opportunity
for African-Americans in
the early 1910s and 1920s.
Roddy and Ella and Leo Moon
were his aunt and uncle.
Roddy Moon was a
paterfamilias kind of a guy.
He was one of the founders
of the NAACP in Cleveland.
He had a federal government job
as a meat inspector, you know.
And he let everybody know,
you know, that he wasn't going
to accept second-class
citizenship.
They also moved beyond the
bounds of segregated Cleveland
and into sort of
an early version
of an affluent neighborhood.
And after Joseph's sight
was completely lost,
the family relocated
again to Cleveland
to this house at Everton Avenue.
And even though, you
know, sort of went
through the Cleveland
slides quite quickly,
you know that by the time you
get to sort of the mid-1920s,
Cleveland is the sixth largest
metropolis in the United States.
It was big city.
Chester Himes, you know,
sort of grown up in this sort
of small country towns, you
know, not so far from Vicksburg
and Lorman, Mississippi.
He'd lived for a little
while in Augusta, Georgia.
St. Louis was a big city,
but still, you know,
maybe in a smaller neighborhood.
And to heavily industrialized
Cleveland,
his family bought a house in
a Jewish neighborhood in many
of the northeastern
and midwestern cities,
that's the pattern of migration.
African-Americans
followed Jewish Americans
into somewhat suburban
neighborhoods often.
And Himes graduated
from high school,
one of a very few black students
at an integrated high school
in the Jewish neighborhood
in Cleveland.
It's worthwhile to remember that
Langston Hughes also has sort
of a similar academic career
and it's just a few years
older than Chester Himes.
In the summer of 1926,
Chester Himes graduated
from high school-- he graduated
in January and he's working
at this really posh hotel,
the word park Manor Hotel.
And African-Americans had all
the service jobs, the busboys,
the porters, the
custodial staff.
And one day he was flirting
with two young white women,
and I sort of mention this
because it's going to wind
up coming up again and
again in the work and life
of Chester Himes'
interracial desire.
He was flirting and he steps
backwards towards the elevator
doors and the doors open,
but the elevator car had
passed to the next floor.
Himes free fell about 20
feet and he hit the bottom
of the elevator shaft.
He broke several
of his vertebrae,
he broke his wrist off
in half, he chipped all
of his teeth, he broke his jaw.
I think he ruptured his spleen.
It was an incredible-- I mean it
was incredible that he survived.
He was rushed to a hospital
and he was put in a body cast
and he had to convalesce for
a period of about 10 weeks.
During this period
of convalescence
on the hospital ward, he's
surrounded by people who died,
one person from blood
poisoning, another person
from heart attacks, sudden heart
attack, and he also started
to receive, you know,
very powerful opiates
to reduce the pain.
Himes then matriculate
to Ohio State University.
He again is about
four years ahead
of someone like Jesse Owens.
And Ohio state, the state of
Ohio, if you graduated from one
of the high schools, you could,
you know, sort of make your way
into the freshman class and they
did not bar African-Americans.
What they did was they prevented
you from participating in sort
of the fullness of college life.
You couldn't live
in the dormitories.
They only had dormitories
for men at that time.
You couldn't turn the social
clubs or eating clubs.
You know, your social existence
was completely separate.
And it was sort of
during this moment
that Chester Himes really
began a lifelong rebellion
and also an incredible sense
of criticism and circumspection
about the African-American
middle class and black strivers.
And there's some sort of really
remarkable stories that come
about helping us understand the
resilience of black social life
in the 1910s and the
1920s like the founding
of the famous black
fraternities and sororities.
And some of us think that the
most famous of them were founded
in 1911 and have
the colors crimson
and cream, but there are others.
And Chester Himes, you know,
was striving to belong to one
of the others Alpha Phi Alpha
which is found at Cornell.
Kappa Alpha Psi was founded
at Indiana University.
Omega Psi Phi is also founded
in 1911 at Howard University.
And so he was sort of in
this group of black strivers.
The son of Oscar Depriest,
the first African-American
congressmen
in the 20th century
representing Chicago is one
of his classmates.
And, you know, he's
thinking, hey, you know,
I'm going to be a doctor,
I'm going to be a doctor.
But as I said, Chester
really started dealing
with some rebellion and some
0rebelliousness and also,
he's still sort of getting like
all of this pain medication
and he received a
compensatory stipend
from the Ohio Industrial
Commission.
So then he was also like a super
wealthy freshman in college.
This is at the same
moment that Josephine Baker
and Ethel Waters are wowing
and tantalizing audiences
with this new music
and these new dances
and the strong sexuality
of the 1920s also was
right there for Chester.
It's a great picture.
This is the-- it's not the--
This is the earliest picture
where you have sort of
a close-up of his face.
This is Chester about 17, 18.
He is a nice-looking young man.
He flunked out of school
and returns to Cleveland
where his parents have divorced.
They've sold the elegant home
in the Jewish neighborhood.
They're constantly bickering
over what the child
support payments should be.
His father who had been an
esteemed professor is now a
custodian at a nightclub.
And on the portion of Cleveland
that Chester would know best,
you have a series of bars,
salons, gambling dens
and brothels really very close
to where the African-American
middle class would have been
if you were in the
segregated neighborhood.
And the-- you know,
I want to say sort
of like the environment
pulled him in.
And Chester started frequenting,
especially gambling club
and he became good at black
jack and he became good at craps
and he started to
get a reputation.
And soon enough, Chester
was a part of like a--
not a syndicate, but a part of
a crew of, you know, robbers.
And they decided to steal
pistols from the YMCA.
Now, why they used to
store pistols at the YMCA?
I can't tell you.
But they-- you know, sort of--
they got some pistols
from the YMCA,
they drove to Youngstown
to sell the pistols.
He was arrested and he goes
to trial with short pants on
and the judge says, oh look
at this clean cut young guy.
You know, he never would
have done anything, you know,
sort of this dastardly
or what have you.
He was paroled to the
care of his parents.
His mother and father
were fighting
about how he should
be disciplined.
And in the late fall
Thanksgiving of 1928,
Chester decided on a lark after
getting a tip about some money
and jewels at the home
of Mr. and Mrs. Miller
that he would try
a daring robbery,
and he conducts a home invasion.
He waits for them in the garage.
He forces his way in, he steals
the money and the jewels.
And he goes to Chicago
where he was arrested
and brought back to Cleveland.
And here again, Chester
is-- he's 19.
And, you know, he had received
a lot of support from his family
when he'd had these
other sort of--
I wouldn't say criminal
peccadilloes, but, you know,
were the-- all of the
stolen items were returned
and they paid restitution
and, you know,
he promised never
to do it again.
And Chester went before a judge.
One of the rulings I did notice
from Judge McMahon was
upholding racial segregation
in housing in 1928 in Cleveland.
But he does before judge
McMahon shortly after or just--
it's right around
Christmas 1928.
And the judge throws
the book at him.
And if you look at the ledger of
who came before Judge McMahon,
you know, sort of on that
day, Chester gets basically
as much time behind bars
as everybody else combined.
So before he was 20, before
he had graduated from college,
I mean he never returned to
college, he was an inmate
at the Ohio State Penitentiary.
Prison in the 1920s is
somewhat similar, I mean more
or less similar to prison today
with perhaps two exceptions.
It was designed to break the
will of incorrigible men.
And one of the things that
the guards did to do that was
that they used fairly
vigorous corporal punishment
that would have been
a steady part
of one's experience
of incarceration.
And, you know, he's very
regimented, very harsh
and also African-Americans
were expected
to work in the coal company.
They basically crushed coal
and fed coal to the boilers.
It was outside work and it
was considered the lowest
and most degrading of the
jobs that one had in prison.
Because of his injuries, Chester
did not work in this company.
He was in a company that they
called the "Crippled Company".
And they had somewhat
preferential treatment.
So-- But in 1929 and 1930,
this wasn't really the
thing that consumed him.
What happened was on April
21st, 1930, the largest fire
in American prison history broke
out at Ohio State Penitentiary
taking the lives of more
than 320 men, many of
whom were burned alive.
Many-- probably the
majority, you know,
suffocated from smoke
inhalation.
And it was a classic
case of really a--
an invertible tragedy and
also a very painful kind
of travesty, if you will.
What happened was once
the fire broke out
and the guards understood what
was going on, they started
to let some of the
prisoners out and they began
at the bottom tiers and
worked their way up.
And ss you can imagine
by the time,
it's the sixth tier cell block.
And by the time they got
up to the third floor,
the heat was unbearable.
And so everybody
perished, you know,
if you were on the
fifth and sixth blocks.
And the prison guards--
rather the prison
superintendent's point
of view was he was standing
on the outside of the gates
with a machine gun
trained at the entrance.
And so it's sort of this
experience of seeing
such catastrophic loss of life
that Chester Himes really began
to turn inward and to think
of himself in a literally way.
Almost immediately he
begins producing incredible
short stories.
By 1934, Esquire magazine is
founded either right at the end
of 1932 or in the
beginning of 1933.
By 1934, African-American
Chester Himes is publishing
short fiction in Esquire
magazine alongside Ernest
Hemingway, John Dos Passos.
They are, you know,
sort of bringing
out a Leon Trotsky has
something in Esquire.
Langston Hughes is the other
African-American writer.
Esquire is definitely sort of
a transformative publication
for American literary
sensibilities
and it really begins to sort
of present the American male,
not necessarily as
the breadwinner
and father figure but, you
know, sort of more as the sort
of like a hip-- James
Bond kind of a figure.
I'm looking for a metaphor.
Himes becomes one of their
most highly regarded artists
and he publishes during
this time in venues
like Esquire what we call
"White Life Stories".
So there are only secondary
African-American characters.
The protagonists to
the short stories read
into what Red Hill are white
American men and they're all,
you know, sort of enraged
and you're sort of dealing
with their inner world and
the struggles that they have
about confinement and, you know,
sort of longing and desires,
sexual desire but
especially, again,
this rage at being in prison.
And Chester then starts to think
about what his career would be
like as a novelist,
somebody who sort
of writes his way
out of incarceration.
He has a couple of
really strong advantages.
One of them was his cousin
Henry Lee Moon, this is the son
of Roddy and Leah, so
it's his first cousin.
Henry Lee Moon winds up
being the press secretary
for Robert Weaver who is the
first African-American, sort of,
like the housing secretary in
the Roosevelt administration,
he-- Weaver is the highest
ranking black cabinet person
in the 1930s.
You all have heard of the what
they call the kitchen cabinet
led by Mary McLeod Bethune that
includes people like Weaver
and with also, you
know, sort of gesture
to other African-Americans who
would have been sort of leaders
in either the union movement
like a Philip Randolph or people
like Walter White,
the secretary of NAACP
and then his deputy Roy Wilkins
and then the sterling
attorney Thurgood Marshall.
But Henry Lee Moon knows
all of these people, right?
They're all actually
intimates of his
and he's this important
journalist,
he's the first person to break
the story in the New York Times
and really international
press about the shift
in electoral voting patterns
that will enable
African-Americans who've moved
to major Northern
Metropolis to be able
to shift the balance
of power, right?
If the African-Americans get
behind the Democratic candidate,
then those candidates will
win because the balance
of power has shifted with
this new black migration.
And, sort of, Henry Lee Moon
brings that out in a series
of articles in New York Times.
And he really inspires Chester
who wants to sort of, you know,
stay even with his
brother who earns a PhD
and then also his cousin,
you know, sort of a big shot
in New York, and Himes starts
thinking once I can get
out of prison, you know,
I can sort of make it.
What happens also
with the fire is
that the Ohio State
Parole Board begins
to take its work seriously
and they start to parole men.
So all of a sudden, he has
this 20-year sentence hanging
over him and it's reduced
to a seven-year sentence.
So Chester comes out in 1936,
he goes back to Cleveland
where he's, you know, trying
to make it as a writer and sort
of hitting his head against
the wall as all writers do,
right, as all writers must.
In the company of a really
progressive white couple
who have founded
a playwright house
for African-American artists,
the zealous, they introduced him
to one of the most popular
writers in United States,
Louis Bromfield who has this
sort of remarkable place
in Ohio called Malabar Farm.
Katharine Hepburn and
Humphrey Bogart get married
at Malabar Farm in 1945, right?
So, Bromfield is, you know,
highly regarded, he is rich,
he seems to know what
he's talking about.
He says, hey, Chester, you and
your wife Jean, you will come
out to Malabar for the summer, I
will introduce you to the people
in Hollywood, I'll take
your manuscript to New York
to my publishing
friends and, you know,
I will sort of make your career.
One of the things that's
fascinating is that one
of his great friends, Louis
Bromfield's great friends,
was Edna Ferber the author
of "Showboat", you know,
that sort of brought Paul
Robeson really to the floor
of American culture when
he sings "Ol' Man River".
And Edna Ferber had
a hand in the career
of the African-American
novelists Waters Turpin
who publishes several novels
at the end of the 1930s.
Waters Turpin's mother
had work for Edna Ferber
and Turpin himself had soft
of served during the summers
when he was in college as,
you know, sort of a help
around the house or at
parties, that sort of thing.
My mother is here with us
today and she had Waters Turpin
at Morgan State University
as one
of her English professors,
right?
So I think that Bromfield wanted
to do Edna Ferber one better.
And he said, I'm going to take
this African-American ex-con
and I'm going to
make him, you know,
big major literary celebrity.
And so Chester took him at his
word and he goes to California.
That's what Bromfield said.
He said, you know, you need
to go out to Los Angeles
where they're making
all these prison movies
in the summer of 1940, 1941.
And so, Himes moves out there
and he gets the door shut
in his face every
place that he goes.
People love Esquire.
They know him from Esquire.
They think that this sort of
tremendous work, but they say,
hey, man, you're way too black
to be in these places, OK?
And so, Chester becomes
quite bitter about, you know,
his rejection and
it's more than that.
In fact, he had learned
that the--
that the racial integration
practices
with the war services
industries in California
where specially you have,
you know, you've got shipyard
and then you also have
these air force industries,
and these places are as
segregated as if you're
in Louisiana or Texas
or Alabama.
And he says the only
thing that's different is
the attitude.
He says that whites
in California expect
you to be grateful.
And he was absolutely disgusted.
He at this time becomes more
and more closely connected
and enamored of the
very far left
but especially the
communist party.
In the book I wrote called
"Indignant Generation" I say
that we should really think
about sort of three institutions
that have given us the
indignant generation.
The generation of black writers
who really change national
attitudes towards issues of race
and also some issues of
what I think could be called
American imperialism.
But the Communist Party,
the Julius Rosenwald fund
and the Federal Writer's
Project would be the three.
The Communist Party
is very significant
as the first interracial
organization genuinely
interracial organization
that cultivates African-American
writers.
And so Himes gets to
know this sort of side
of the world more
intimately in Los Angeles.
He had worked as Federal
Writers' Project writer
in Cleveland in the end of the
1930s, at the end of 1930s.
And you know, all of
these ironies they get--
he and Jean get this house.
Sorry, I should go
back because I didn't--
excuse me, so that's
his wife, Jean Himes.
They meet when she's 16 and
he's 19, and Chester Himes,
the taller too, and then the
shorter couple are the leaders
of the communist party.
I-- This is not in the book,
I only learned this actually
after the publication
of the book,
somebody identified
the photograph,
but that's the two couples.
But the nicest house that
they ever lived in was one
that became available to them.
Why? Because of the
Relocation Act
that removed Japanese citizen
from Los Angeles, right?
And this is halt off by
1943 in what we call--
sometimes we call them
the Zoot Suit Riots.
In 1943 is as incendiary a year
as 1968 but we don't remember it
that way, which is interesting.
In Los Angeles you had groups of
servicemen combing neighborhood,
beating Latinos and blacks who
are wearing the latest fashion
of the day, the Zoot Suit.
And Chester said, he sat at this
house with a riffle on his knee
and he did that in
preparation of white mobs coming
to drag him and Jean out.
You see a dramatic shift in
his writing in 1943, 1944.
He published in the NAACP
and in the Urban League's
journals fairly what I would
call fairly conservative
publications, you know,
I mean geared towards
the black middle class,
geared towards the white
philanthropic interest
and he's starting to
publish these really biting,
trenchant pieces that
advocated direct assault,
revolutionary practice against
the regime of segregation.
During in act-- during wartime,
remember this is sedition.
So negro marauders are
needed, you know, at that time
for revolution is now.
And again they're coming out in
these mainstream publications.
As you know, this didn't sit
well with the powers that be
and so you get-- he
started to be a target
of the FBI right at this point.
Chester Himes was undaunted.
These kinds of being
surveilled or rejection,
sometimes even more direct
kinds of persecutions,
he never faced him and he wrote
what many people consider his
most daring and outrageous work
"If He Hollers Let Him
Go" let him go right
at this moment 1944, 1945.
And if you think of "Native Son"
by Richard Wright, you know,
this book that sells
500,000 copies in 1940
as having an undercurrent
of sexual tension
between Bigger and Mary Dalton.
Remember Mary Dalton is
accidentally suffocated
as Bigger as carrying
her or he has carried her
into her bedroom, her mother,
sightless mother
appears in the doorway.
This novel "If He Hollers
Let Him Go" is about the
over current of interracial
sexual desire.
And in fact it's a very dramatic
story in the book where I talked
about what he's done to
this book when it is going
through the process
of publication.
Chester does meet Richard Wright
and he moves to New York or,
you know, sort of relocates
to New York where he
and Wright become friends.
Chester also, unlike other
writers who were sort of,
you know, playing the game
with publishers and reviewers,
he was combative if you,
you know, sort of came out
and you said hey, you know,
"If He Hollers Let Him Go"
was not sophisticated literary
technique, but especially
people who disagreed
with his politics,
he had words for you.
And he often put them in print
in mainstream publications.
And he could sort of show
himself well for photographers
when he wanted to but he was
also widely known as a person
who was very fond of
a taste of whiskey.
He became friends with Carl Van
Vechten, a literary tastemaker.
Van Vechten, you know, sort
of gave us this really
remarkable photograph
in 1946 that's on the
cover of the book.
Van Vechten was probably
the white man
that Himes was closest to.
They remained friends throughout
the rest of Van Vechtens's life,
he died in 1964 and Chester
always needed not just sort
of emotional or spiritual
support, but he often
like most writers
needed financial support,
and Van Vechten was
very good that way.
Chester also got to know Ralph
Ellison and Fanny Ellison.
In fact this is Chester's
shot of Ralph
and Fanny while they
are sharing Thanksgiving
in 1946 together--
1947 together.
They were very close
friends, 1946, excuse me,
I'm looking at that thing.
Don't look at your own slides.
So the novel that I think
he should be best known
for is called "Lonely Crusade".
"Lonely Crusade" never
comes out in paper back
in an American edition.
So that's part of the reason why
we sort of don't really know it.
The books that are
available now are ones
that are-- they're UK editions.
Chester around this time
really began the most snarled
and complex and combative
antagonistic hostile
relationship with publishers of
any writer I'm familiar with,
but certainly among
African American writers.
And he wanted this
book to be, you know,
sort of the great prize
winner and bestseller,
but unfortunately it flopped.
And this was the-- in some
ways, this is the book I think
that we still need to digest.
I mean, this is the book about
the difficulty of black labor
and the creation of a bonafide
black middle-class and,
you know, basically this is
a suggestion that we have,
you know, great distance
to travel.
When his friend Ralph
Ellison read it, he said,
you know Chester you've
betrayed me intellectually
and they fell apart as friends.
Ellison was becoming
known at the end
of the 1940s is really the--
not just the great black
intellectual, but somebody who,
you know, understood
themselves to be, you know,
sort of the great
artist and it's sort
of like Langston Hughes
and Chester Himes,
he's still like peasants
in some ways of, you know,
sort of a lofty picture
of Ralph Ellison.
And Ellison would often
say to admirers, you know,
that he thought that Chester
was intellectually dishonest.
And it was sort of interesting,
Chester featured a, you know,
sort of kind of ad
hominem attack on Ellison
in the novel "Lonely Crusade".
It's hilarious, you
really must read it.
Chester who was also was friends
with the guy in the center,
was Horace Cayton,
one of our sort
of under known African American
reviewers, intellectuals,
writer in his own
right from Chicago.
But despite the support of
a really a group of people,
Chester still could not sort of
make it in the United States.
And so, in 1953, he left the
United States really never
to return with the exception
of, you know, sort of 10 months,
11 months and it's really
coming down in 1955,
but he would take the
United States as a tourist.
And so, he had this
sort of, you know,
pretty good early success
when he went abroad.
He had some of his
novels translated like
"Lonely Crusade",
which is called
"La Croisade de Lee Gordon".
And then he also was able to
finish writing another work
of his, which is
incredibly import called
"The Third Generation" and that
was completed while he was sort
of traveling Europe,
living in Spain,
living in the United
Kingdom, living in France.
And it's sort of funny that
when they advertised this book,
even though Chester and
Ralph Ellison had a--
some people say it's
a night fight.
They had a night fight
on New Year's Day,
1953 just before Chester leaves.
And they still had to go to
Ralph Ellison for a quote
when they advertise the book
in "The New York Times."
On his way overseas, Chester
met this woman, Willa Thompson,
who was sort of from
an American blue blood,
blue vein social register
kind of a background.
She was a Smith College
graduate, you know,
she had relatives
who were ambassadors.
She lived in Belgium and
had a family in Belgium
and she had distinguished
herself also during the Second
World War.
And they had this sort of torrid
love affair where, you know,
they wanted to get married
and be an interracial
married couple,
but the burden really
was quite extraordinary
in the early 1950s, even for
people living abroad certainly
for people trying to make a
living as a writing couple.
And I think that one
of the reasons why Chester
didn't publish a book
in 1955 was that he spent
so much time writing letters
to Willa Thompson and she
certainly sent him about 100
of these, you know, four or five
pages single-spaced documents,
you know, it is sort
of exhaustively go
through every dimension
of their relationship.
And what's fascinating was
that Chester was often accused
of using people and
it's not clear
to me how he would've
been able to use her.
I mean I think in
someway she got the better
of the relationship.
But in 1967, he was asked by
the New York Times book review
to talk about his
work of fiction
that he enjoyed the most, and
he used that as an opportunity
to really expose some
of the intimacies
of their relationship.
Overseas, we have
the reconstruction
of really unimportant and
very, very significant milieu
of writers and intellectuals,
which would write James Baldwin,
Chester Himes, Oliver
Harrington,
William Gardner Smith.
And that was a shot of Wright
and Harrington at the caf,
James Baldwin is there,
there's William Gardner Smith,
he was from Philadelphia.
And smith is, again, far left
African-American novelist,
political figure
in Philadelphia,
he's a youth organizer against
segregation and then, you know,
sort of goes overseas.
And then also more recently
sort of the man of the hour,
Richard Gibson, another really
a literary protg person
who wins fellowships
and prizes at 19 and 20
and then goes overseas.
When the Trump administration
released the JFK files,
the last batch 19,000 documents
were released in January
or at the end of December.
It was revealed that Richard
Gibson actually was a Central
Intelligence Agency agent.
And this had been something that
he had been accused of mainly
by Chester Himes
as early as 1957.
And the documents that we
have from the agency files,
I don't know that it's
necessarily the total release
of Gibson material.
I requested these materials in
2004 and was told, you know,
that there was really
nothing to find,
but that Gibson began
certainly a formal
and official relationship as
a clandestine agent in 1965.
So as I said, Chester
was the overseas person.
And so I'll get to
the punch line.
The final shift in his career--
we would have called him sort
of a naturalist writer,
a social realist writer
in the language of
James Baldwin.
But in 1956 living overseas even
though he just published the
novel called "The Primitive",
which is about a weekend
interracial love affair
that ends in violence
and murder.
But he had sort of
fallen in like
with a young German
actress, Regine Fischer,
and they live together in
Paris in the poor quarter.
I mean, he always talked
about eating dog meat
because that's what to be
thrown out and, you know,
they were surviving on that.
And she fell madly
in love with him.
She esteemed him, this
is also at the time
of the famous black writer's
conference in Paris in a 1956
and she attempted suicide
several times that fall
and was eventually sent
to her parents in Germany.
And it's right at that
moment that French publisher,
editor of the Gallimard
publishing company,
Marcel Duhamel, approached
Chester Himes again
for the second time
in about two years
about writing a detective
fiction.
And Himes thought that it was
really low work beneath him,
but he was starving and
so he agreed to do it.
And Regine Fischer she backed
him up and she would say,
you know, you can turn it into
great literature and, you know,
sort of go ahead and,
you know, give it a try.
And the result was a novel
called "For Love of Imabelle"
or "A Rage in Harlem"
turned into a film
in the late 1980s
starring Forest Whitaker,
Gregory Hines, and Robin Givens.
And the plot was given Chester
by my Baltimore home boy,
Walter Coleman who
was an artist.
And Walter said that the
plot is about the scam
where you say you're
going to turn, you know,
$500 into $25,000 and
it's called the blow
and Chester developed this plot
into a really absurdist
novel giving you the crisis
of black urban life
at the same time
that you can see
the hopelessness
of liberal American
political solutions
to that sort of crisis.
And this is what took Chester
forward to a new generation
and made him so influential in
the 1960 because unlike many
of his peers, maybe
especially Ralph Ellison
who had sometimes a very
difficult relationship
with the writers of the
1960s and early 1970s,
Chester was beloved
by these writers.
I just want to get to a couple--
I'll show you a couple
of slides.
For one thing, Chester Himes was
thought well loved and was sort
of connected to Malcolm
X because he continue
to write political journalism
even though living abroad
and he would always make this
really, really cutting remarks
about the capacity of the United
States to overcome its history
of slavery and racial
segregation.
And you can see Chester really
taking in some ways in France
at the time, remember that
Charles de Gaulle was the victim
of an assassination attempt
in, I think it's 1962
and Chester is sort of calling
out the French far right
and is also comparing them
to the state of Mississippi,
and he was always, you know,
sort of very outspoken,
very vigorous.
And when Malcolm
X visits in 1964,
in November 1964
interestingly enough, right?
He goes to see Chester Himes.
Chester Himes had become--
he said when this magazine
cover was published in French,
he said, everybody thought that
it was Nasser, and he'd sort
of become like these elder
statesmen of the, you know,
Pan-African, Pan-Arab world.
Pan-African world,
I mean, you know,
Nasser is the Prime Minister
of Egypt but that this was sort
of a kind of a literary cultural
and political statesmanship
that had the sort of
transnational boundaries.
And I'll leave you
with one final image.
I actually, I really
love this photograph.
This is-- Chester
Himes died in 1984.
He was bed ridden pretty much
the last year of his life.
And because of the fall
from about 1973 onward,
I mean it was very difficult
for him to get around.
And he went into a wheelchair,
I think, sporadically at the end
of the '70s and then more
or less permanent
confinement for the 1980s.
But this photograph gives you
a sense of the indomitable will
of this black man from
Cleveland, from Jefferson City,
from Lorman, from Augusta, from
the Penitentiary and then also
who scaled the absolute heights
of American literary stardom,
as well as international
literally stardom.
He always said that
people always talk a lot
about James Baldwin.
I think James Baldwin was so
great there but I'm better known
in France than James Baldwin is.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
We have time for some questions.
>> I had a question.
What happened to his wife, Jean?
[ laughter ]
>> Lawrence P. Jackson:
Thank you.
So, Chester met Jean, as
I said, as sort of right
after he leaves school.
And they meet at
kind of a wild party,
and the wild parties were
always in the alleyway.
And he said he first started
carrying a pistol because he had
to protect the two of them, but
especially men that wanted to,
you know, sort of take
advantage of her and turned her
out onto the street
as a prostitute.
She married while
he was in prison.
She married one of the people
who was in his burglary gang,
who was as a fellow burglar
and part of the gang.
And they got divorced shortly
after Chester Himes
was released.
And then he and Jean
really began what seem
like a genuine partnership.
I mean well beyond
romance that lasted
until he left the United
Stated through the 1940s.
But what was fascinating
about the relationship,
and that was a source of deep
bitterness and strong insecurity
for Chester Himes
was that arguably
because of his prison record but
he believes that it actually had
to do with the preference
of American institution,
but especially American
liberals,
maybe just American liberals,
the strong preference
that they had for black
women over black men.
She had a flourishing career
in what was originally--
first she worked for sort of
nascent social welfare agencies,
the USO during the Second
World War, recreation
and social services at
women's confinement facilities.
And he always, you know, again
was quite bitter and insecure
about the success that
she had more or less
in the white color
white world that he felt
like he was consistently denied
and it had something to do
with again this bitter wrangling
that he always had
with publishers.
And they also had a tremendously
tempestuous relationship.
Both were heavy drinkers
and did and said things
under the influence of alcohol
that they then later regret it.
And they, you know, sort of
went back and forth in the--
from 1948 for the five years
until basically the
relationship collapsed in 1952.
And then they were
formally divorced in 1976
and he remarried Leslie Packard.
I'll show you the
slide of her who was--
became the caretaker
of his literary estate.
Thank you for the question.
>> If I understood correctly,
if I understood you correctly
the rest of his life,
he spent in Paris,
was he buried there?
Did they ever go back
to United States?
And would he have
had more impact
if he would have
come back to America?
>> Lawrence P. Jackson: To begin
at the end, yeah, I have to
or I would hope that he
would have had more impact
in the United States if
he lived here, you know,
for the rest of his career.
He was the kind of
person temperamentally
who found really any
residue or vestige
of the condescending attitude
of racism and the practices
of racial segregation
absolutely unbearable.
So he felt like he needed
to leave the United States,
I'm not to be able to endure
that, so in '53 he goes
to Paris really just
for vacation.
He lived in London for about
six months and they moved
to Spain for, you know,
a couple of months,
then he came back to Paris.
He goes to the US for more
or less all of 1955 and back
to Paris for about three years,
moving around Europe quite a bit
and then he settles
in Spain in 1969.
That's when the house
that he started building
in 1967 was complete and then he
completely relocated to Spain.
He spent with several amounts
time in places like Amsterdam,
wherever he sort of
met friends and people
who were conducive to, you
know, sort of the things
that he was interested in.
>> Was he buried?
>> Lawrence P. Jackson: Yeah.
And he's buried in Spain.
He's buried in Moraira in Spain.
Thank you so much.